Speaker 1: All right.
Before we move off of C PAC for the day, just
a couple other little highlights from other
speakers at CPAC, Texas 2022, of course, Mike
Pillow Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell continues
to be obsessed with machines.
You guys remember his obsession with machines?
Speaker 4: We're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines.
Speaker 1: He made the principled and defiant
and scary announcement at CPAC that 54 countries
have now been taken by the machines.
Speaker 4: And this is very important.
You hear me on this.
Over 54 countries have now been taken by the
machines are getting taken by the machines.
Yeah.
And you never get to go back.
Venezuela, Australia, they're gone.
Speaker 1: Australia does not use voting machines,
by the way.
Speaker 4: Don't get to vote out the machines
once they're there.
Once they're there, you don't get your country
back.
Speaker 1: So as you can imagine, obviously,
I now have that on my soundboard as well.
Speaker 4: Over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines.
Yep.
Speaker 1: Here's Ted Cruz, Texas Republican
Senator Ted Cruz.
He now has this pronoun quip that he uses
at every opportunity and the crowd loves it,
but he just sounds so dumb.
Speaker 4: Well, my name is Ted Cruz, and
my pronouns are Kiss my ass.
Whoa.
Speaker 1: That counts as clever and interesting
for the American right.
Here is Rick Scott.
Rick Scott, who's a Republican senator of
Florida.
I challenge you to follow what the hell Rick
Scott is talking about here.
This is bonkers stuff.
Speaker 4: Everyone will obey and no one will
be allowed to complain.
If you do, speak up, boom, you're going to
be canceled.
Cancel your views if you don't conform with
big tech.
Archie or Neil Young.
Can we take it off?
Spotify, YouTube, Facebook and Twitter?
Yep.
Speaker 1: In fact, I expressed displeasure
at two Neil Young songs, and we're about to
lose our YouTube channel.
It's crazy out there.
Speaker 4: The militant left America are the
modern day version of book burners.
Speaker 1: No.
He was expecting more applause on that one.
Did you see he does this pause and you can
tell he's expecting more applause.
And when it doesn't come, he just waits.
Speaker 4: Modern day version of book burners.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: That's right, says one guy canceling
silence.
Speaker 4: Impending from the Internet is
book burning.
These are the most narrow minded, intolerant
people our country has ever seen.
Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: Really struggling with the applause
lines.
And I also didn't realize Rick Scott's diction
was so poor.
Like, I didn't realize he was this bad of
a speaker.
Speaker 4: They are completely ignorant of
both world history and American history.
Socialism leads to two things poverty and
oppression.
Speaker 1: There's no socialism here.
I mean, that that may or may not be true,
but the U.S. isn't a socialist country.
Biden's not a socialist.
Democrats are not socialists.
Speaker 4: Social is not a new idea.
It's one of the dumbest, oldest and most discreet
ideas of the 20th century that resulted in
the deaths of 100 million people.
If he's Democrats who have no idea how the
real world works, are acting like they just
invented socialism.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So just an electric speaker, Rick Scott.
Impossible to follow.
And then lastly, here is Marjorie Taylor GREENE
again saying Christian nationalism is a great
thing.
Speaker 2: But when I said that I'm a Christian
nationalist, I have nothing to be ashamed
of because that's what most Americans are.
We're proud of our faith.
Speaker 1: Yeah, very untrue.
Many Americans are nominally Christian, but
Christian nationalism, meaning this inextricable.
Intertwined nature of Christianity and government.
Most Americans are not for that.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is just flat out wrong.
So an absurd, absurd CPAC.
Texas 2022.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this with the results of the Alex Jones trial.